[音楽]
hey
入った
今日あの
僕なの高校生もですねきていてしかも先生も来ているので
うんなんかこう授業参観みたいな感じで恥ずかしいんですが
あの今日はのし横からやってまいりました
ちなみに
北海道出身以外という形てぃ今日どれくらい来てるんですかね
ああやっぱり結構多いんですねまぁ半分以上なのかなどうもありがとうございます今日
は他大学で
らせて頂きますのでちょっとそれにちなんだ話から始めたいというふうに思っています
ボーイズビーアンビシャスまあこの言葉はねものすごい有名な言葉で実はの国立大学で
というのは基本的に建学の精神というのはもってはないんですね
でも他大学っていうのは日本の大国立だけでものすごい珍しく
この boys be ambitious という言葉が周りと建学の精神の4です
ね方はれる機会が多いんじゃ
が行くなというふうに思っています
多分
今日は北海道出身の方も北海道しじゃない方も
今日は北海道大学の出身の方も岡田育に直接ね関係ない方も来た来ていらっしゃると
思いますけども
でも
ほぼここにいるすべての人がこの言葉 boys be ambitious
の言葉についてはご存じだと思いますたぶんこれだけ人口に膾炙している多くの人が
ですね知っている
北海道にまつわる言葉ってなかなか無いんじゃないかなと思うんですね
boys be アンペア数
日本語で訳すと
まあ有名な訳ですけれども青年を対象高いというふうに訳されるわけですが
されて皆僕たちはねなってきたな
でもよくよく考えたらちょっと英語で勉強していくと本当に boys be
ambitious って青年よ大死を抱けっていうニュアンスで
暗く先生は言ったんだろうかということを皆様と思いますか
ちなみに
アンビシャスという言葉をですね英英辞書で翻訳すると
7位探し目ですねこういうふうにいうわけですね
波部がストロング wish とぅ日サクセスするパープル終わり
閉校する
パープル dick
立地
リッチになる
そういうふうになるということをまあこのアンビシャスって言葉はね
含んでるんだというふうに思うとなんとなくこの日本語で優待処理だけっていう
ちょっと理想論的な話よりかもう少し高現実的なというか
力強い言葉のように思
皆さんはいかがでしょうか
ぼいずびーあんびしゃつ
僕には猫の言葉って改めてまあ今日ね保護台に来るにあたってもう1回考えたんです
けど
クラーク博士はひょっとしたらね大志を抱けという割とやんわりとした言葉ではなくて
並行車誰こういう風なニュアンスをね行ったんじゃないかなっていう気も
ちょっとしたんですね
今日集まっている我々僕はこの大学にね直接学んだわけじゃないですけども
でも今日はまさにこのアイディアはスプレーティング
こういうふうに北海道大学にねまつわるアイディアという風に考えた時にこの成功者と
いうことをね少しコンセプトに今日は考えてみたい
そんな風に思っています
成功のコンセプト
あの
まあ僕自身はね今43歳で3年前に先ほど紹介がありましたけれども
高校の先生になりました
学校の先生でもないし教員免許もないし
まあ元々おじいちゃんが作った60年前に作った高校が経営が厳しくなったのでやら
ざるを得なかったというところから
校長にこれ形になったわけですが
北海道にもそもそももうすごい久しぶりに帰ってきた
3年前ですまぁそこから
おかげさまで戦とも場合に増えたり大学の進学率も30%か60%に場合になったり
つい最近は全国紙で奇跡の高校だという形で3日にわたって特集されたり
まあそんな形で取り上げられる機会が増えてきています
もちろん新を高校の建て直しもしくは再建
もしく新しい学校作りっていうのがまだ終わっているわけでもないしまだ途上でしか
ないので成功しているかどうかということがはっきりと僕が言うのはおこがましいん
ですがそれでも今日はせっかくの話
皆さんに僕が伝えたいことがあるとするとですね一つ
成功のコンセプト子がこの3年間感じていることを冠して今日はみんなに共有したいと
思っているんですね
それは
この3年間ね
うがすごく感じたことはいざ北高校の校長になりますという話をしたときに誰一人
いいねっという風に言ってくれなかったんですね
ありとあらゆる人が反対した
絶対やめたほうがいいと
高校の校長なんてしかも潰れそうなしかも
学力が低いしかもこれだけ札幌でもいろんな評判のある
そういう高校の建て直しなんて絶対に無理だからやめておいたほうがいい
そういうふうにね
相談したありとあらゆる人に言われたんだね
まあ言われる度にやっぱりちょっとで苦しくなる傷つく
そうなのかなって自信がなくす
でも結局まあやらざるを得なかったやろうと思ったし
そうは言われてもでももう心に決めた
て3年間走ってきたんですけど振り返ってみるとじつはあのときに多くの人に反対され
たから今があるんじゃないかなというふうに思うのね
つまり成功のコンセプトって実は多くの人が反対するところにこそ
実はこの種があるんじゃないか
そんな気がします
例えばここ他の大学もうすごい大学
きっと皆さんはねいい大学に入っていい会社に入っていい仕事をしてい人生を送る
そういうことを求められてきたしこれから求められていると思う
そういう中
例えばいい大学に入らなかったらいい会社に入れなかったら
もしくは自分がこういうことをやってみたいと思うことをねやろうとしたときに
ひょっとしたら多くの人がねなんでせっかく北大言ったのに
せっかく良い会社に内定もらったのにせっかく良い会社に勤めているのになんでそれを
やめて
新しい仕事をしたり高校の校長になったり農家になったりわかんないですけど
いろいろ言う人がいるかもしれない
でもぜひ覚えてほしいのはそうやって多くの平地が
せっかく公なのに
絶対そんなの無理だよ
いう時こそ実はチャンスなんだということをね
ぜひ
覚えてほしいなというふうに思いますみなさんはイラ役に来ている
いい会社にきっと入るだろうそういう人であればあることね
そこから脱するってことにねもうのすごく苦しくなってくる
僕もすごい苦しかった
でもこれからの人生っていうのはもしくはこれからの社会っていうのはね
そういうことができる人というのをきっと求められているんだろう
そんな風に思っています
クラッカー風が言う boys be ambitious 数
それが成功者たれということであれば
そうやって自分が大事にしていたもしくは周りが大事にしている信念を
打ち破って前に進むことそれは孤独だし
ひとりぼっちかもしれないけども突き進んでいくこと
これこそにヒントがあるんじゃないかそんな風に思っています
きっと北大ができたとき札幌農学校が出来た時に
そんな北海道に行って
どうすんのっていうふうに多くの皆さんの先輩たちは言われたと思うんですよね
それでも行ってそこでチャンスをつかみたい
そう思った若者たちがこの北大というのを作ってきたんじゃないか
今日僕たちはその場にいさせてもらっているんだなと思っています
なので今日はねまあせっかく
ですから
僕の次の
夢
こういうことをやりたいということですね皆さんに共有したいというふうに思うんです
ね
新を高校は
日本一に本気で挑戦する所の母校になるこういうふうに言い続けてるわけですけども
これをぜひね
もっとさらに推し進めていきたい
これを沈めていくとどういうことが起きるかということを
まあこれは結構多くの人からは夢物語だ
そんな風に言われるんですけどもで僕は絶対にこれが実現する
そんな風に思って
これをちゃんとおおぴらに日までいうのはね
しかもインターネットの前で言うのは今回初めてなので
共有したいというふうに思っています
あの神をここでは今年ターン9コースというコースを作りました
このコースの話を寝させていくもらいますこれらの今年の入学式の入学式の直後の写真
です
24人の生徒たちがいて
この生徒たちの真ん中に何かいろんなものが住んである
実は入学式で入場して体育館でやったものが終わった後にみんなが初めて教室に入った
ときの光景がここから始まりました
いわゆるこういうスクール形式の
机と椅子があってという場所ではなくて
可動式の椅子で可動式の机が真ん中に置いてあってその上にいろんなスタッフが置いて
あります
選手とかペンとか
これから1年間3年間この子探究コースの子たちが授業で使っていくいろいろな
スタッフ
いろいろな教材がツールが机の上にドンと置いてあって
彼らはまずここから
これをどうやって片付ける
どうやってこれから1年間この教室を使いながらどこに一番配置するのが一番いいのか
そういうことをねみんなで話し合ってしまっていく教室をつくっていくところから実は
授業が始まりました
探究コースというのは全く新しいコンセプトで出来上がっています
ひと言で言うと
今までの教育はもしくは我々が受けていた皆さんが受けてきた教育っていうのは
偏差値を大事にしていた
ですよねテスト勉強して高い偏差値を望んでいく
でも今探究コースで作ろうとしている
コンセプトは偏差値ではなくて経験値を大事にしている
偏差値から経験値そういう世の中にこれからなっていくしそういう世の中でもうすでに
なっている
そういう世の中で活躍できる人材を育成していきたいと思っているのね
偏差値が中心の学校っていうのはどうしても一人で勉強していく
みんなも受験勉強ってもちろん友だちはいたかもしれないけど基本的に一人で勉強して
た
でも実際どうでしょう今日は社会人の方もたくさんいますけども大人になったら一人で
仕事をするなんてこともまずない
必ずチームで仕事をさ
そのチームだって
いろんな対応性がある男の人と女の人
先輩と後輩
野球が好きな人嫌いな人
歌が上手い人下手な人いろんなチームがあってその中で一つのプロジェクトをやって
いく
こういうことを最初から高校の時からこういう学び方を見つけていく必要があるんじゃ
ないか
そういうことで
そういうコンセプト中心にしてこのコースを作りました
プロジェクトベースとラーニングという言い方をしています
すべてがプロジェクトに基づいて授業が行われる
皆さんや次の授業っていうのは国語英語数学理科社会という風に
縦割りになっていてそれぞれの教科書を使ってそれぞれの学びの横の連携というのは
ほとんどなかったと思うんですね
でも
この
探求口数
プロジェクトベースラーニングではいそれを横軸で作ってますひとつのプロジェクトに
対してできるだけ多くの強化が変わるようにしている
例えばこれリサイクルアート展に出展するというプロジェクト
生徒には設けていてそれに対して美術や科学や世界史や国語や現代社会
そういった授業がいろんな形でこのリサイクルアート展に出展するという
プロジェクトに対して授業としてかかわっていきますそうすると先生たちの役割って
いうのは教科書を教えるではなくて
パシリ低床になっていく
生徒と一緒に考えていくなぜなら正解はないからですね
もちろん生徒は
様々な
リサイクルアートの出店の作品を作りますもちろんここには正解はない
でもこれを通じてみんなたくさんの事を学んでいきます
なぜならこのプロジェクトは全て日沿ではやらない
4人から6人の生徒たちで必ずチームを作って必ず
対話をしながら学んでいく
対話をしながら説明していくし理解しようとする
この説明したり理解したり受け入れたりもしか悩んだり
そういう学習をしながらそこに学習の原点があるんじゃないか
だーインターネットで検索もするしそれを説明もするし
ホワイトボードも使うしこういうことを授業でやってきています
また
なぜがこの校舎の中でしか授業ができないのかと思っていてこれは帯広でキャンプ場で
キャンプをしながら普通に授業をやっています
アウトドアフィールドで星を見ながら
山を見ながら川を見ながらそれを実際触りながら
何のためにこういったものがあるのかそれが何のために学問つながったのか
そういうことを勉強している
こういうコースをつくって今ものすごく注目を浴びています実際生徒たちの成長ももう
すごく早くて
自分たちが何のために
こう購入のか何のために大学に進むべきなのか
ひょっとしたら大学に進まずとも
やりたいことをやるためにはこういう道があるんじゃないかそういうことをたった一年
九世の半年間の学びでみんな考え始めている
悩みながら考えている
大学には行くもんだいい大学に行くもんだ
そういう価値観じゃないことに高校生たちが気づき始めている
僕がやりたいこと実現したいことは
この探究コースのネットワーク化です
全国には高校が5000戸あるうちに選考が
私立高校です
3前項が公立高校この高校はいろんな効果あります普通高校商業高校でもすべて皆学校
独自のカリキュラムを持っているそうですよね
学校独自のもというと時間割を持っているわけですが仮にこの時間割がみんなで共有化
されたらどうだろう
探究コースが多くの高校に入っていって
月曜日の一弦2弦は美術3件4件は世界史
こういう同じカリキュラムを持っていったらそして高校ごとに違うプロジェクトやって
いった
が何が実現するだろう
そうここ生が高校3年間自分の高校に縛られなくても
つまり高校移動することができるんじゃないかと思うんですね
なぜ北海道の高校生が自分の地域の高校に3年間いなければいけないのか
ひょっとしたら名古屋の高校ニック名古屋の高校生が翁の高校に行くいろんなそこで
プロジェクト違いを学んでいくプロジェクトを学んでいく
文化の違い人の違い
もちろんホームステイをしなければいけなかったりいろんな壁がたくさんあります
でも皆さんのように
世の中に大学に行く子たちは決して多くない
60%しかいない
多くの高校生がこうやって地域をたくさん移動するんだったら100万人の高校生に
とって非常に価値があるんじゃないかと
そういうふうに思っていますこれをなんとか
10年間で
こういう世の中を実現したいそんな風に思っています
今日は冒頭に
暗くの話をしましたけどもご存知ですか
クラークの言葉には続きがあるという風に言われています
これはひょっとしたらクラブが言ったんじゃないんだという説もあって真偽のほどは
定かではないんだけど僕は実は高校大学受験を失敗した時に浪人生だったときに父親
からこの言葉を贈られました
そして僕はこの言葉を
自分の机に貼って机の前に貼って1年間勉強し続けてきた
こういう訳です
青年よ大志を抱け
金銭やがよくのためではなくまた人呼んで名声という虚しいもののためでもない
人としてらして起きなければならないあらゆることを成し遂げるために青年よ大志を
抱け
僕たちの人一緒のミッションがあってそれを成し遂げるために今日たぶんこの場に来て
いるんだと思います
おっどうもありがとうございました
[拍手]